and finally new role someone has to tell
me when did America decide to redesign
its entire economy based on everyone
rating everyone else every interaction
doesn't have to be followed by a survey
let's bring back I give you money you
give me light bulbs I mean both go on
with our lives enough with it was it
good for you to look I just want to [ __ ]
I don't want to talk about your good
qualities and where you can improve
because you're not my girlfriend you're
roto-rooter snake my drain and move on
Amazon doesn't need to do a follow-up on
every purchase how did you like that
shower curtain great it blew my mind
when they asked would you be willing to
share your experience yes let me get
right on that I was gonna screw the wife
after dinner but let me sit down and
type out a 300 word story about how much
I liked your [ __ ] cookie how many
times when you're on hold have they
asked you to stay on the line after the
call to answer a survey why would I want
to stay on the line after the call when
I can't get someone on the line during
it
how would you rate your customer
satisfaction oh definitely a four as in
for [ __ ] sake leave me alone when did
American business get so insecure I was
even asked recently to rate my
experience in the airport bathroom which
was poor I did not meet a single
Republican Congress
look come on it's an airport bathroom
what do you want me to say of all the
urinal cakes I've ever pissed
laguardia's are the finest why does
Deniz need to be on Yelp it's already a
way to tell if Denny sucks there's a
sign out front that says Denny
[Laughter]
does everything have to be reviewed
people review salt cat says 5 stars
I used daily with some food how about
this if you didn't like the way a
company conducted its business stop
using it this seemed to work for the
first million years of Commerce the
practice of rewarding a company with
repeat business or going somewhere else
and if enough customers did that it
would shut down and become a Halloween
storm people's jobs shouldn't depend on
some Rando judging them and I don't want
a narc on hard-working people and shitty
jobs Millennials might be into that
because they love to judge count me out
if the waiter forgets my salad I get
over it
I don't whip out my phone [ __ ] you're
going down
[Music]
and stop raiding me I don't want to have
to be on all the time when I get into an
uber
I just want to chill out and enjoy the
Armenian disco music I would give 10
stars for just one honest uber ride hi
I'm your uber Dan I hate my life I'm
your ride bill I'm hungover so shut the
[ __ ] up it's not a good mental space to
be in to constantly be asked to rate
each other we're supposed to be the
freedom people we're always being
watched and tracked and raided run
camera traffic lights and ringing
doorbells at the ATM were being watched
at gas stations and in elevators and
parking lots married people complain
they can't cheat anymore cos cellphones
and cars are now tracking devices it's
impossible to have an affair because
Siri can't keep her [ __ ] mouth
I don't want to become China where they
have a Social Credit system where you
get brownie points or demerits for your
behavior as it is observed by cameras
and by your fellow citizens almost like
a financial credit score except it's on
you a human being who sometimes has a
bad day you can't ever have one now
let's not go there which is why I have
created a new site called rotten er
tomatoes where you can review the
reviews of other reviewers
I came up with that when I was stoned
and I'm going to give that weed a nice
review
you